[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Serien guten Abend freut mich
dass sie dabei sind eine ziemlich
attraktive Champions League Partie hast
du später im Blick hat ja die verspricht
Fußball vom Feinsten schönen guten Abend
und was wir noch haben zeigen wir Ihnen
jetzt im Überblick
Moskau feiert Sieg über Nazi Deutschland
Putin bezichtigt den Westen Krieg zu
führen Kanzler Scholz wirft ihm
Machtgehabe vor
Treffen mit deutlichen Differenzen
Deutschland und China streiten über
Menschenrechte und eu-strafmaßnahmen
gegen chinesische Unternehmen
das neue heizungsgesetz kommt aber über
den Starttermin und die Bedingungen gibt
es Diskussionen
[Musik]
der Sieg über Nazi deutschland ist einer
der wichtigsten Feiertage in Russland
und wurde dort wieder mit Militärparade
Propaganda Show und Putin Rede
inszeniert dazu gehörte auch wieder dass
der Präsident den Überfall auf die
Ukraine rechtfertigte und von einem
Krieg des Westens gegen sein Land sprach
und trotzdem war es diesmal etwas anders
nur ein einziger Alter Kampfpanzer rollt
dann der Spitze der Militärparade der
sowjetische T34 eröffnet Putins
propaganda-show moderne Panzer fehlen in
diesem zweiten Kriegsjahr
rhetorisch aber Trumpf der russische
Präsident wie gewohnt auf
[Musik]
es wurde erneut ein echter Krieg gegen
unser Vaterland entfesselt aber wir
haben dem internationalen Terrorismus
eine Abfuhr erteilt und wir werden die
Bewohner des Donbass schützen und unsere
Sicherheit gewährleisten
nachdem mutmaßlichen Drohnenangriff auf
den Kreml vergangene Woche bewachen
nationalgeristen die Straßen ist der
Rote Platz noch strenger abgeriegelt als
sonst
Putin schürt das Trauma der Russen
damals war es Nazi Deutschland heute
greifen die Ukraine und der Westen
Russland an so seine Erzählung
scheinbar hat der besten vergessen wozu
die Wahnsinnigen Ansprüche der Nazis auf
eine Weltherrschaft geführt haben und
sie haben vergessen wer dieses
schreckliche totale böse zerschlagen hat
das Russland wieder für eine gerechte
Sache kämpft sollen auch die
ausländischen Gäste beweisen Staatschefs
ehemaliger Sowjetrepubliken die erst
gestern ihr Kommen angekündigt hatten
und zumindest symbolisch an der Seite
Putins stehen
zur Einschätzung gehen wir zu Vögel gab
was kannst du uns zum Tag in Moskau
sagen
ja das war schon in vielerlei Hinsicht
einen besonderer Tag des Sieges hier am
Morgen fiel erstmal auf wie leer die
Moskauer Innenstadt war es waren kaum
Fußgänger oder auch Autos unterwegs
diese Drohnenangriffe der letzten Wochen
die brennenden öldepots die Explosionen
an Bahngleisen all das hat den Krieg
eben näher rücken lassen dementsprechend
hoch waren die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
hier und es kam auch nicht zu
Zwischenfällen wohl aber zu sagen wir
einem Störgeräusch denn der Chef der
Wagner Söldnergruppe hilft gegen der hat
sich mal wieder mit einem Video zu Wort
gemeldet und er hat mal wieder das
russische Verteidigungsministerium
scharf kritisiert und das ausgerechnet
genau zu dem Zeitpunkt als der
Verteidigungsminister und seine Truppen
sich auf dem Roten Platz feiern lassen
wollten und das eben nicht nur für den
historischen Sieg über Nazi Deutschland
sondern durchaus auch für die
derzeitigen Kampfhandlungen in der
Ukraine
vielen Dank nach Moskau für begabt ja
und während Putin heute wieder gegen den
Westen wetterte gab es entsprechende
Republiken von Ursula von der Leyen und
Olaf Scholz in seiner Rede vor dem
EU-Parlament warf der Kanzler dem
krimml-chef Macht gehabt bevor die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin war heute
schon zum inzwischen fünften Mal in der
Ukraine und erneuerte die EU
Unterstützung ultra über große Linien
und Solidarität
es ist eine kleine Parade aber die
Symbolik ist groß die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin gedenkt in
Kiew der gefallenen Soldaten die Ukraine
bereitet gerade ihre Offensive vor und
hofft auf mehr Waffenlieferungen von der
Leyen ist auch hier um keine Zweifel an
der Unterstützung Europas aufkommen zu
lassen
ich bin hier um ihn zu versichern dass
sie sich auf unsere Solidarität
verlassen können solange es nötig ist
der deutsche Bundeskanzler ist auch in
Sachen Zweifel Bekämpfung unterwegs
viele in Europa wünschen sich mehr
Führung des Kanzlers bei der Debatte zur
Bewaffnung der Ukraine wirkte Scholz
zögerlich der Kanzler deshalb mit klarer
Botschaft an Präsident Putin
2200 Kilometer nordöstlich von hier in
Moskau des Putin heute seine Soldaten
Panzer und Raketen aufmarschieren
lassen wir uns nicht einschüchtern von
solchen Macht gehabt
bleiben wir standhaft die Kopfhörer des
Kanzlers vielen bei der Aussprache aus
aber er braucht sie gar nicht die
anschließende kritik kam aus den eigenen
koalitions rein Führungsschwäche der
Vorwurf Reise Herr Bundeskanzler sind
sie mit der Zeitenwende angetreten was
die Ukraine angeht aber dann wird es ein
ganz vielen Stellen hier in Brüssel und
Straßburg häufig so und in vielen
Hauptstädten der Europäischen Union als
müsste man ihn jede konkrete Maßnahme
mühsam abbringen der Kanzler wird auch
weiter im Olaf scholzstil führen daran
wird sich trotz Kritik wohl nichts
ändern
auch in Berlin haben viele Menschen an
russischen Gedenkveranstaltungen zum Tag
des Sieges teilgenommen Angehörige des
russischen Konsulats erinnerten mit
Grenzen an die getöteten sowjetischen
Soldaten nur Gästen der Botschaft war
das zeigen russische Embleme erlaubt
deshalb mussten etwa Sympathisanten
einer russischen nationalistischen
Rockergruppe ihre Fahnen abgeben
jetzt zu einem atmosphärisch er heiklen
Termin Außenministerin bärbock empfing
in Berlin ihren chinesischen
Amtskollegen chingang
China da war doch was bei ihrem Antritts
Besuch dort hatte sie gerade erst sehr
klare Worte in Sachen Taiwan und
Menschenrechte gewählt waschen danach
als schulmeisterlich zurückwies auch
Chinas Rolle im Ukraine Krieg belastet
die Beziehungen Präsidentin könnte
Russland unter Druck setzen tut es aber
nicht dass kritisiert Berlin wie gesagt
ein heikler Termin heute Andreas
der Besuch aus Peking kommt nicht nur
sehr kurzfristig fast überraschend nach
Berlin er kommt auch noch zu früh artig
wartet die Delegation um die Ecke vorm
Auswärtigen Amt es muss China wirklich
wichtig sein nach ihrem Streit in Peking
wollen die Minister berborg und Ching
Gong das Verbindende suchen aber alles
Trennende ist noch da Werbung bitte
China erneut Russland zum Rückzug aus
der Ukraine zu ersuchen aber Gin meint
erneut nicht Russland sondern allgemein
beide Seiten Werbung kritisiert dass
China kriegsrelevante Gütern nach
Russland exportiert und stellt
Strafmaßnahmen der EU in Aussicht aber
Gin fühlt sich nicht an die Sanktionen
gebunden wir erwarten aber von allen
Ländern wir erwarten auch von China
dass es auf seine Firmen in dem Sinne
entsprechend einwirkt wir würden im Fall
von Strafmaßnahmen gegen China strikt
und streng reagieren
dann kritisiert bärburg das China
während Ihres Besuchs in Peking den
Menschenrechtsanwalt Jürgen jeng
Festnahmen daraufhin kritisiert Shin
Gong bärburg
wir verbitten uns dass sich die
ausländische Seite in unsere inneren
Angelegenheiten einmischt vielen Dank
wie Sie sehen gibt es noch viel zu
besprechen schönen Tag noch zumindest
einen Streit können Werbung nach außen
hin beilegen die Ausladung von
Finanzminister Lindner diese Woche habe
Termin Gründe und nichts mit dessen
China Kritik zu tun alle deutschen
Minister seien in Peking willkommen
israel hat in der Nacht gezielt 3
Kommandeure der militanten
Palästinenserorganisation islamischer
sie hat getötet insgesamt starben bei
den Luftangriffen im Gazastreifen 13
Menschen darunter auch Frauen und Kinder
die israelische Armee begründete ihren
Militärschlag mit mehreren
raketen-streifen in den vergangenen
Wochen
vielleicht gehören Sie dazu Millionen
machen sich gerade Gedanken über das
umstrittene Gesetz zum Heizungstausch
die Debatte über eine mögliche
Verschiebung wird dabei lauter statt
2024 fordern immer mehr den Starttermin
für neu einzubauende und klimaneutrale
Heizungen nach hinten zu verschieben
neben Branchenverbänden kommt dafür auch
aus der Ampel echter Zuspruch allerdings
nur von einer Partei Britta Buchholz
die Installateure können sich kaum
retten vor Nachfrage allein der Verkauf
von Wärmepumpen stieg um mehr als das
Doppelte doch es fehlt an Personal der
heizungsverband plädiert nicht nur
deshalb für eine Verschiebung des
Gesetzes
ein noch nicht verabschiedetes Gesetz
fast keiner im Detail kennen wo noch
keine Fördermittel bekannt sind wo die
soziale abfeder noch nicht klar ist die
klar sind da ist es glaube ich eine
Frage des Realismus dass man sagt in dem
komplizierten Bereichen gehen wir uns
lieber noch mal sechs bis zwölf Monate
Zeit das gut vorzubereiten der
Wirtschaftsminister Gerät stärker unter
Druck das neue Gesetz soll eigentlich
zum ersten Januar 2024 gelten
verschieben oder nicht die drei
ampelpartner sind sich uneins das Signal
an die Menschen ist ganz klar und das
muss von diesem Gesetzentwurf auch
ausgehen dass eine Entscheidung für eine
fossile Heizung eine schlechte
Entscheidung ist wir können nicht
einseitig auf die Wärmepumpe setzen
sondern auch andere Technologien werden
eine Rolle spielen wenn das mehr Zeit
braucht wir wollen am Ende ein gutes
Gesetz haben wie gesagt dann sollten wir
uns diese Zeit nehmen ich glaube es ist
überhaupt nicht zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
angetan über zeitliche Dimensionen zu
sprechen wenn sich drei und eins sind
freut sich die Opposition die Union will
ein grundsätzliches aus der Gesetzes
Reform
wir wollen der Bevölkerung die klare
Botschaft geben dass wir aus Sicht der
Unionsfraktion alles tun werden was in
unseren Möglichkeiten steht um diesen
kann es nicht anders sagen Wahnsinn der
da geplant wird Seins der
Bundesregierung zu stoppen verschieben
oder nicht am Freitag berät der
Bundesrat mehrere Länder fordern bereits
eine Verschiebung des Termins und zwar
um drei Jahre
morgen ist flüchtlingsgipfel im
Kanzleramt und die Länder die werden mit
einem eigenen gemeinsamen Papier zum
Treffen kommen ihre Forderung der Bund
soll die Kosten für Unterkunft und
Heizung für geflüchtete komplett
übernehmen außerdem wollen sie eine
monatliche pro-kopf-pauschale für
Empfänger nach dem
Asylbewerberleistungsgesetz und auch bei
der Integration und anderen Folgekosten
soll der Bund mehr übernehmen an was ist
in den Kommunen fehlt darüber berichtet
unsere Reporterin Cornelia schiemens sie
und ihr Team sind für das Projekt ZDF in
gerade in Chemnitz
220 ukrainische Schüler lernen in dieser
Chemnitzer Schule noch denn ab Sommer
ist damit Schluss die Stadt braucht das
Gebäude für den Betrieb einer
Regelgrundschule die ukrainische Schüler
müssen dann verteilt werden wohin unklar
der Oberbürgermeister klagt es fehlen
Lehrer Betreuer Schulplätze so können
Integration nicht funktionieren da
warten wir dass wir nicht allein
gelassen werden wir sind auch bei den
Kapazitäten quasi am Limit da braucht es
Geld da braucht es auch Ressourcen
bundesimmobilien zum Beispiel
Unterstützer bei den Erziehern und das
muss schnell gelingen denn im Moment
reicht es nicht aus Platz ist in
Chemnitz nicht das Problem 5000
Wohnungen stehen leer aber bei der
Integration hapert es gewaltig wenn die
vielen jungen Leute keine Arbeit haben
dann haben sie zu viel Freizeit und
wissen nichts mit sich anzufangen
erstmal Deutschkurse anbieten den Leuten
damit zu Deutsch lernen dann finden Sie
hier auch Arbeit mit den Deutschkurs und
alles und das fehlt die 19-Jährige
Nazanin aus Afghanistan kam im letzten
Jahr nach Deutschland wartet seitdem auf
einen Sprachkurs die AWO Chemnitz
unterstützt die junge Frau sich durch
die deutsche Bürokratie zu kämpfen
es ist so verwirrend für mich wo kriege
ich all die Informationen und Scheine
her das weiß ich nicht
hier in der täglichen Flüchtlingsarbeit
ist allen klar es braucht
Bürokratieabbau mehr Deutschkurse eine
schnellere Anerkennung von
Berufsabschlüssen mehr Geld vom Bund
kann da nur der Anfang sein
ob Angriffe auf Flüchtlingsheime oder
Gewalt bei corona-demos politisch
motivierte Kriminalität erreicht im
vergangenen Jahr einen neuen Höchststand
das belegen aktuelle Zahlen von
Bundesinnenministerium und
Bundeskriminalamt insgesamt wurden fast
59.000 Delikte gezählt 7% mehr als im
Jahr zuvor die größte Bedrohung für die
Demokratie bleibe der Rechtsextremismus
Andrea Maurer hat die Details
Hass und Hetze nicht selten folgt darauf
Gewalt 2022 gab es 120 Anschläge auf
Flüchtlingsunterkünfte
1420 politisch motivierte Straftaten
gegen geflüchtete es ist in höchstem
Maße menschenverachtend Menschen zu
attackieren die vor Krieg und Terror
geflüchtet sind und bei uns Schutz
gefunden haben während die Zahl links
motivierter Straftaten von über 10.000
auf 7000 um 31% zurückging legten rechts
motivierte Straftaten von knapp 22.000
auf fast
23.500 zu plus 7%. noch höher war die
Zahl wieder klar rechts noch links
zuzuordnen der Straftaten gut 24.000
plus 13 Prozent viele davon Anfang des
Jahres noch im Zusammenhang mit
corona-protesten später auch im Kontext
Ukraine und Energiekrise durch den
furchtbaren völkerrechtswidrigen
Anschlag Putins in der Ukraine ist auch
für die innere Sicherheit in Deutschland
eine Zeitenwende gefolgt Einfluss von
72% im Vergleich zum Vorjahr auch im
Bereich Klima und Umweltschutz
1716 Fälle ein Großteil bei Aktionen von
klimaaktivisten insgesamt haben sich die
Fallzahlen politisch motivierter
Kriminalität seit zehn Jahren verdoppelt
also Allzeithoch der Fallzahlen das
Spiegel die politischen und
gesellschaftlichen Spannungen aufgrund
multiple und sich überladender Krise und
Konflikte wieder
in Teilen der Bevölkerung sehen wir
Radikalisierung Tendenzen
corona-zunehmend polarisiert das lässt
offenbar auch die Zahl politisch
motivierter Straftaten steigen
dutzende Busreisende sind heute in
Brandenburg verletzt worden als ihr
Fahrzeug und ein Lastwagen auf der A12
zusammenschließen die Polizei spricht
von 52 Verletzten darunter 10
Schwerverletzte in dem Bus saßen
Jugendliche und Erwachsene aus Polen
ausgelöst hatte den Unfall offenbar ein
Lastwagen der beim Überholen auf einen
vorausfahrenden Lkw auffuhr und gegen
den Buspreise
ja sie ist fast mit Händen zu greifen
die Spannung vor der Wahl in der Türkei
am Sonntag wieder der autoritär
regierende Langzeitpräsident Erdogan
oder der Pro europäische
Oppositionsführer chiliter in Umfragen
gibt es ein richtig enges Rennen und da
könnten die 1,5 Millionen bei uns
lebenden Türken zum Zünglein an der
Waage werden für Sie heute die letzte
Chance zum Urnengang luisen aus
Stuttgart sie alle wollen mitbestimmen
wer die Türkei zukünftig regiert auch
wenn sie selbst dort nicht leben viele
haben in dem Land Wurzeln dort leben
Freunde Familie und für manche hier am
Wahllokal in Stuttgart steht viel auf
dem Spiel wenn ich ein Land wie
Deutschland in einer Demokratie leben
kann dann möchte ich dass meine
Landsleute das auch schon 20 Jahre her
das heißt ein Mann die ganze Zeit
regiert hat und es muss sich was ändern
sie hoffen auf Oppositionsführer Kilic
stavulu mit ihm würde sich die Türkei
den Werten Europas wieder annähern viele
andere Vertrauen weiter Erdogan wünschen
sich dass er in der Welt eine führende
Rolle übernimmt
was er gemacht hat war richtig schon
jetzt zeichnet sich in Deutschland im
Vergleich zu 2018 eine höhere
Wahlbeteiligung ab diese könne einen
Unterschied machen so der Vorsitzende
der türkischen Gemeinde in Deutschland
deswegen können natürlich die Stimmen
aus Deutschland sehr entscheidende Rolle
spielen dass die Wähler hier
Uland Einfluss
wäre wirft der Erdogan Regierung vor
Druck auszuüben der türkische Staat
versucht direkt oder auch indirekt über
Organisationen Einfluss auf solche
Menschen zu nehmen das ist offenkundig
und das geht nicht bei uns der
Wahlsonntag in der Türkei er wird
spannend und emotional auch in
Deutschland
so jetzt sind wir beim Sport und bei dir
Katja in der Fußball Champions League da
geht so langsam in Richtung Entscheidung
ja heute und morgen stehen die
Halbfinals an leider ohne deutsche
Beteiligung dafür mit einem Mailänder
Derby und heute Abend mit der Partie
Real Madrid gegen Manchester City und da
könnte einer den Unterschied ausmachen
er ist die größte Attraktion derzeit im
Weltfußball Erling Holland der
norwegische Torjäger von Manchester City
bei der Ankunft in Madrid heute Abend
will er gegen Real treffen und sie
wollen das verhindern die Königlichen
Real Madrid träumt vom Finale und von
Champions League Titel Nummer 15
es ist doch so wir haben schon jede
Menge dieser Spiele erlebt ich vertraue
auf unsere Erfahrung wir wissen was wir
zu tun haben
[Musik]
eines Tages kommen wir ins Finale und
gewinnen es aber wir sind hier um es
jetzt zu schaffen
Spannung jedenfalls ist garantiert und
jede Menge fußballerische Feinkost
beim freiwasserweltcup in Ägypten hat
Olympiasieger Florian Wellbrock seinen
zweiten Sieg gefeiert nach dem Triumph
über 10 km gestern gewann er heute auch
mit der mix-staffel und noch mal zum
Fußball die Deutsche Fußball Liga will
mir mehr Geld erwirtschaften vor allem
durch einen neuen Investor auf einer
Podiumsdiskussion in Dortmund sollten
heute auch die Fans davon überzeugt
werden die Zeichen der Fans sind
vielerorts eindeutig sie sind
größtenteils gegen einen
investoreneinstieg nennen es den
Ausverkauf des deutschen Fußballs die
Vertreter der deutschen Fußballliga
argumentieren jedoch dieser Geldregen
eine Sofortzahlung von 2 Milliarden Euro
sein notwendig um den deutschen
fußballwettbewerbsfähig zu halten ich
kämpfe nicht seit 20 Jahren für den halt
vom 50 + 1 damit ich hier durch die
Hintertür ein Trojanisches Pferd hier in
die Bundesliga lasse als Gegenleistung
für die
20 Jahre lang 12,5% der Einnahmen aus
der nationalen und die internationalen
medienvermarktung erhalten ob dieses
Projekt umgesetzt wird entscheidet sich
in gut zwei Wochen dann treffen sich die
Vertreter der Profi-Vereine und stimmen
darüber ab
und ich bin mir sicher darüber werden
wir dann hören Dankeschön Katja ja die
Aussichten die sind eher regnerisch wo
sogar dauerregendroht erfahren Sie
gleich von Katja horneffer um 21 Uhr das
heute journal Christian Sievers
interviewt Finanzminister Lindner das
gesamte 19 Uhr Team sagt schönen Dank
schönen Abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute entwickelte sich
zunächst eine Schauer Staffel hier im
Westen Deutschlands und dann setzte am
Nachmittag von besten kräftiger Regen
ein dieses Regenband holte die Schauer
Staffel ein und jetzt in der Nacht zieht
das Regenband weiter nach Osten an den
Alpen setzt kräftiger Dauerregen ein und
morgen über Tag wird dieses Regenband in
die Länge gezogen dahinter gibt es dann
weitere kräftige shower zum Teil auch
Gewitter unter dem alten Rand singt die
Schneefallgrenze heute Nacht ist es am
ehesten trocken hier im Nordosten und in
den Mittelgebirgen am Alpenrand und im
Nordosten sinken die Temperaturen auf 8
bis 6 Grad sonst bleibt die Nacht bei 12
bis 9 Grad milder und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 12 Grad an
den Alpen und 22 Grad in der Uckermark
und von der Ostseeküste bis in die
Lausitz wird wohl am freundlichsten sein
sonst gibt's häufig Regen und diese
Regen ist oft mit Gewittern durchsetzt
zwischendurch werden sie auch mal die
Sonne zu Gesicht bekommen am ehesten
trocken hier in Süddeutschland ist es
Richtung Saarland
Pfalz und auch in schwarz der Dauerregen
am Alpenrand lässt nur vorübergehen mal
nach und erst zum Wochenende wird es
davon Norden deutlich sonniger und auch
wärmer guten Abend